não conhece o primeiro é uma é um grupo
é que faz espetáculos no mundo todo
e a gente começou a trabalhar para
desenvolver um espetáculo no brasil
nesse processo eu me deparei com essas
tais 6 lentes criativas para enfrentar o
mundo e elas não eram lights na verdade
e esse processo ele começou é do momento
em que eu estava em nova york em um bode
criativo com outras 178 diretores
criativos ea gente estava discutindo
sobre o conteúdo a gente vai fazer uma
apresentação no carnaval no rio de
janeiro e um dos esquetes que a gente
apresentar eram esquete que falava é que
é brincar um pouco com os movimentos de
chão de rock'n'roll as pessoas
balançando a cabeça e levantando foi
legal interessante mas eu como um
tradutor cultural nessa minha função é
pra vamos fazer umas dancinhas então foi
legal a canon voltar pro brasil
trabalhei fez uma pesquisa incrível de
referências de danças nessas doenças
todas que a gente vê
voltei pra nova york estavam os mesmos
oito caras ou assentados na mesa
esperando e aí foi muito engraçado que
quando fui passar aquele momento foi
inesquecível para mim eu eu gostaria de
apresentar para vocês pra mim foi o créu
factor por uma casa na minha pesquisa
quando eu comecei a mostrar a primeira
música era do créu
e eu falava do movimento e aí quando
terminou lembra assim deles olhando fama
o que a mente
e é muito difícil explicar o créu cara
né não é assim não creio na verdade o
movimento não mas é assim você é é
sexual não é na verdade uma dança mas é
de que claro cara não rolei e saquei que
não dava para explicar o créu
culturalmente é impossível explicar o
que é ou você vive o créu
você não sabe o que é
e nesse nesse processo eu entendi que
precisava na verdade é que precisava
entender como me comunicar
não era uma questão não era o inglês era
cultura e dentro da cultura a gente tem
padrões de valores e padrões de
comportamento
a gente tem o que há fora do padrão de
comportamento e aí eu esbarrei um cara
que achei muito interessante o filósofo
e sociólogo francês o edgar no ranking
não sei se alguém já teve a oportunidade
de ler e é muito interessante porque o o
homem fala uma coisa quando você está no
território em que as coisas você não
está entendendo direito polariza
transforme norte sul faz uma caricatura
do problema
eu falei vou fazer uma caricatura então
qual é o meu problema eu estou falando
com as pessoas do norte
certo no norte essas pessoas para
sobreviver
historicamente que elas fazem se planeja
né
durante oito meses não têm comida há
muito tempo há milhões de anos
essas pessoas têm que se organizar
planejar pegar o alimento estoca
armazenar entender como elas vão comer
durante oito meses quando elas vão comer
isso é planejamento isso gera um
raciocínio de criar processos
todo ano eu sei que eu sobrevivo se eu
fizer é isso né isso é um planejamento e
se algo dá errado eu paro analiso e
traçar os próximos passos em função do
que eu tenho e de onde eu quero chegar
o raciocínio é um absoluto mas eu estava
tomando a a eu tinha necessidade de
polarizar e aí começou a fazer sentido
no sul
tópico o coco tá no coqueiro sempre
certo
se você tem fome que você faz você vai
até o coqueiro e pega o coco econômico
o problema é que você tem quando fez a
fama de novo você volta provavelmente
você vai encontrar os outros cinco
os mesmos problemas falando e aí como é
que chegou um pouco joga pedra sobe isso
faz com que você não pensa em processo
na verdade isso faz com que você cria
pequenos processos que é o famoso se
vira pode vir aqui agora me viro desse
jeito de viver daquele jeito e é muito
legal porque você aprende 30 maneira de
pegar um pouco
só que provavelmente na 30ª vez que você
inventou se lembra mais a primeira
isso é olhando meio num gráfico
acho que essa seria se eu tivesse que
estruturar o raciocínio do norte e no
raciocínio assim você sai de um ponto
traz algumas possibilidades você vai
andando quando você para que você
entende quais as conexões que você vai
fazer
e anda o nosso raciocínio se eu tivesse
que representar
seria mais ou menos assim na verdade
existe uma organização
só que as linhas se cruzam o tempo todo
é você tem uma é incrível porque se você
tiver um ponto de raciocínio aqui você
tem conexão por outro lado aqui em
alguns lugares você não tem a chance de
se conectar novamente num terremoto que
casa cai primeiro a gente falou que hoje
é de crise financeira quando você está
muito estruturado você quem mais sente
então a tal flexibilidade o jeitinho tem
até um termo que achei sensacional que a
cirurgia a ciência do se vira
é isso existe registrado hoje é isso é
isso que a gente tem a gente se vira a
cara é um processo a gente tá acostumado
evolui andar mas sempre olhando para os
lados para entender o que aconteceu e os
caras não eles param e perguntam se eles
não entenderem que acontece
olha créu amo sorry now cruel eu falei
não é preciso convencer porque eu quero
renovar a maneira com que as pessoas vão
entender esse conteúdo que eu quero
fazer é adaptar um conteúdo que faça
sentido que tenha propósito é para as
pessoas que elas assistem
isso me representa eu sinto quando você
está no espetáculo ea e e você sente
vivo né o life fox é isso é uma coisa
fala com você então culturalmente eu
tinha certeza que eu precisava é
conseguir comunicar isso
e foi aí que eu entendi que eu tinha que
criar algum freio motor criativo para
poder comunicar que língua essa é como
criar e como é a gente ouviu aqui já há
a criatividade é muito difuso é linda
mas é difícil é importante entender os
processos da criatividade
o primeiro momento da criatividade é
imaginar né
você precisa imaginar você precisa
trazer o seu repertório de vida das suas
experiências do seu conhecimento das
suas dúvidas para somente você precisa
ter a capacidade de imaginar coisas
o segundo momento é o conectar que é o
criar essas invenções é quando você
junta duas coisas que são serão pouco
prováveis de serem conectadas você fala
am e se juntar isso com isso tive uma
ideia é essa é a faísca essa é nova é
quando você fala acho que eu tenho algo
diferente e o que é inovar e não vai
implementar né pegar essa ideia que você
teve conseguir fazer então eu acredito
que é é que nem na as palavras né
existe uma sintaxe na criatividade
o que faz você fazer conexões lembra que
na há assim táxi palavras como
entretanto portanto que ela não
significam nada a não ser tirar a
capacidade de imaginar algo de criarem
modelos abstratos
então o que na criatividade seria minha
sintáxi naquele momento para lidar com a
situação que estava vivendo a idéia de
ser um especialista foi preciso ir a um
especialista no bumbum é preciso
entender o que são esses caras e fui a
fundo
para entender o personagem como como
esse personagem se comunica como o
conteúdo é tratado e aí eu descobri algo
muito interessante
existiam alguns padrões já qué tipos ao
qual o personagem sempre está atrelado
quando ele está se apresentando quando
está interagindo com o público e
conversando com os fundadores do
mercosul crise com fio
eles me contaram que no começo é eles se
apresentavam em um vídeo que gravava as
apresentações eles assistiam e percebiam
que alguns shows eram melhores do que os
outros e os shows mais legais eram shows
em que cada personagem transitava mais
dentro dos arquétipos foi interessante
na verdade o teste é um modelo de
organização emocional com qual você se
relaciona com o contexto você se
relaciona com o mundo externo
existem diferentes atléticos e todos nós
de alguma maneira compartilhamos de si
sa ket pois dependendo nossa história
mas existem alguns arquétipos que são
como as cores primárias em que todos nós
de alguma maneira é acessamos para
construir o nosso modelo de organização
emocional né e com o qual a gente
interajam com o outro e com um ambiente
que a gente viveu e os personagens
obviamente no mundo teatral
eles têm que lidar com isso quando eu
entrei dentro dos atléticos no menu o
personagem sempre transita nessa neste
diagrama e aí entender um pouco mais
cada um que é o herói
o léo falou aqui hoje muito de que todos
somos heróis né
de alguma maneira essa a perseverança
força é difícil é comum todos temos as
nossas dificuldades mas a a a
organização emocional do herói é muito
interessante o herói é capaz de se
tornar uma silhueta dele mesmo ele
representa uma missão ele escolhe uma
missão que a minha missão é superar esse
problema eu crie estratégias eu planejo
eu queria objetivos é o acordo assim
também não interessa o que eu tenho que
fazer eu vou fazer para chegar lá
inocente é inocente é o cara do do
coração eu sentimos aquele seu amigo
você pergunta alguma coisa ele demora
três segundos para responder pra ele não
tem objetivo ele se deixa levar ele ele
anda ele sente é o que ele está sentindo
obviamente que um inocente e
principalmente na nossa sociedade é
muitos resistindo como fraco mas lembra
o filme do forrest gump esse cara
conquistou o mundo seis vezes porque
eles se ele vai né ele ele viu o rei do
mundo seis vezes é no outro lado a gente
tem científica o cientista aquele cara
que investiga extremamente racional
sentido é o cara que sai do meio de uma
conversa e começa a olhar para a
conversa
ele entende quais são os elementos quais
são os padrões como é que as coisas se
organiza
ele pode não conversar mas ele vai
entender tudo o que está acontecendo
normalmente os cientistas esse cara ele
se isola do mundo mas ele entra dentro
do mundo e traz para o mundo algumas
informações que o mundo não tem é ao
mesmo tempo esse cara pode se tornar
extremamente chato às vezes ele não
entende onde ele está o que está
acontecendo está tão focado que ele não
olha o que você tem no oposto o
cientista o xamã nettheim chamando a
tribo aquele que te leva no ritual é é
mas a gente tem um chá mais modernos as
estrelas de rock pega de hendrix renato
russo e mais perto da nossa cultura são
shaman são pessoas que transcendem
qualquer coisa se colocam em suspensão
você ouve uma letra você ouve uma música
é o xamã tem esse poder chamar na
verdade o interesse dele é transcender
os limites onde tem um limite e quer
ultrapassar é a fronteira
vamos normalmente leva todo mundo junto
e o fato de não é respeitar limites não
é por acaso jimmy hendrix e renato russo
morreu muito cedo e aí você tem também o
colaborador com a banda colaborador é
aquele cara da manutenção é o cara do
grupo eu acho que uma orquestra
o maior exemplo disso imagina a escada
músico define um talento incrível quero
estudo anos e anos e anos e anos tem um
talento absurdo o que ele faz parte de
uma orquestra ninguém sabe nem o nome
dele
quando você vai no espetáculo a
orquestra e esse cara tá feliz com isso
são é o ritmo o que interessa é o grupo
todo mundo junto com o problema
se você é sempre um cara que se preocupa
com um grupo como o grupo funciona mas é
um cara começa a ficar atrelado a regras
e procedimentos você não gosta muito que
saia fora daquilo que funciona sempre
então você tem de um pouco afinal era
uma pessoa dura prata modelo de
organização colaborador tem esse
problema
do outro lado o provocador que é o
twitter é o bobo da corte é o único cara
que fala pro rei o que ele quiser não é
degolado é porque ele tem uma rua ele é
ele é racional mas ele essa caixa com
ele é perspicaz ele fala as coisas
certas e fora da casinha totalmente mas
é um cara que provoca o cara que você
tira aquele coelho da cartola quando se
mais precisa que fala que o negócio está
andando é um cara totalmente discutível
mas tem twitter
e aí a gente entende acha que todo mundo
aqui se você tentar pegar rapidamente
esses arquétipos você consegue se
enquadrar em algum deles nessa falar eu
sou mais assim eu sou mais assado então
acho que sou uma mistura de um ou de
outro
essas são os nossos modelos de
organização primários ou pelo menos o
que a gente usa números mas ela funciona
pra gente e de alguma maneira a gente
entende quando a gente reconhece a gente
tem de falar que a gente é assim a gente
personaliza porque a gente tende a
manter as coisas a gente fica nesse
lugar falar a minha personalidade é
assim eu sou assim e no fundo você não é
assim você está a fim de você pensar que
isso não é o que você é mas como você
está vendo e transforma esses arquétipos
em lentes que você pode simplesmente
colocar e tirar colocar e tirar
dependendo da situação que você está
enfrentando isso é muito interessante
porque ele faz com que você transmite
você possa transitar entre todos e se
não fica parado em um único lugar
se você continua a ser um herói na sua
casa quando você chega ninguém se
relaciona é com uma missão você se
relaciona com sentimentos
então é interessante entender onde essas
coisas onde esse
o foco pode funcionar ou não e aí a sua
você tende a criar uma personalidade
mais criativa à sua sintaxe criativa
aumenta você começa a entender melhor as
coisas e se você olhar para neste
diagrama é quando a gente separa por
exemplo o herói e o cientista é com isso
que a gente falou o herói
a questão dos seus objetivos o cientista
na análise
você vê que é um modelo de organização
que são totalmente cerebrais são verbais
né eles eles pensam no futuro o herói
não vive um momento e ele resolve um
momento pra chegar onde ele quer o
cientista ele está analisando e está
sempre entendendo o que isso pra que a
gente pode usar isso como isso existe né
está mais um senso de futuro
quando você vem aqui pra baixo o
inocente o xamã
eles são pré bais eles são viscerais é
no estômago no coração e no meio e pouco
nessa transição você tem um colaborador
e o provocador que na verdade eles são
um equilíbrio o provocador por exemplo
ele é visceral porque não tá nem aí com
com o futuro mas ao mesmo tempo é
racional e você tem uma outra análise
interessante que o modelo do lado
esquerdo ele é um modelo que ele tende a
ser mais revolucionário é ele tem um
passo a manutenção do grupo as
descobertas né a quando você está bem
você está equilibrado com seus
sentimentos têm um caráter evolutivo o
lado de cá tem um caráter revolucionário
o herói faz a revolução ele segue o xamã
ele consegue transcender de colocar em
suspensão e um provocador é o discutível
o cara que faz a revolução ele chega e
joga bomba e valeu
e aí eu acho que entra muito a idéia de
inovação se inovar na verdade é
conseguir implementar tão legal
se você cria essa você entende vai
passando pelos processos na hora que
você está imaginando como é que você põe
seu foco você é herói quando você está
imaginando e montando o seu modelo
mental então é essa essa transição de
lentes essa transposição
não é eu costumo dizer que o o hotel
a conclusão que eu cheguei era que essa
transição para inovar na verdade o
grande lance é você conseguir ser um
disciplinar
é a tal mistura das disciplinas quando
você vai a fundo delas você tem que ter
a indisciplina para poder transitar para
poder de alguma maneira é é se livrar
poder entrar dentro de uma disciplina
mas não ficar preso dentro dela
bom depois desse processo todo o créu
foi aprovado tão engraçado assim uma
dificuldade ela acabou gerando é toda
uma outra história
eu acho que assim esse é o meu conceito
o conceito de inovar
eu gostaria que você ficasse com essa
palavra faculdade chamas sejam
indisciplinares né eu acho que essa é
sejam disciplinados para ser
disciplinados quando precisa e para
poder transitar
muito obrigado senhor